exactly I'm here with Yan the game
finished in a draw Yan please show us
few critical moments of this game um
well so he played slav which I I would
say didn't I mean I expected it but like
in was like my first
uh uh first idea that he'll play slav so
well I knew okay this line is like a
long pictures line yeah like I think
there is like one of the Maines here
Rook C it's like Queen sacrifice
for Rook a light piece and into pawns
which is you know roughly equal despite
computer say it's slightly better for
white so I had instead this move Rook C3
which is would be winning if not Knight
E4 so this is pretty much all forced uh
just exchange everything Rook C6 now
Knight B2 is important because B3 is
coming mhm yeah and here okay E4 was uh
like about the last move I
I I managed to remember so I know this
like slightly dangerous for black so if
you I mean if you see this this position
for the first time you can easily you
know make some in accuracy so I think
one of the ideas was just to play
something like Rook G2 Bishop F4 and
Bishop A3 check King B3 and here King
E7 uh maybe maybe not quite here but it
was one of the ideas so maybe like some
some move here like maybe Rook F2 uh as
far as I remember it's just some sort of
a draw but uh well what he did I think
it's in precise already so here yeah
takes I have this extra idea of D5 R G2
yeah Bishop F4 so this is already I
guess dangerous in some way but maybe
it's still you know not still not lost
by Miracle so Rook C8 um Rook B6 my idea
is very simple like Rook B7 and
something and he played here G5 which is
sort of a nice try and uh well I think I
analyzed this position maybe a similar
one and some there there was this move
like Bishop B8 which was like almost
winning or or winning so I in between
like Bishop G3 and Bishop B8 I more or
less quickly opted for Bishop B8 but
maybe bishop G3 was more practical so
for example after A5 Rook
B7 uh F4 Bishop
E1 well
it's it's hard to believe but maybe
something here should be should be good
enough to win but uh well I'm not sure
like say like Bishop D6 giving away like
the bishop but it has I still like black
has some compensation because of this
pawns but well I couldn't really I
couldn't really you know recall so
Bishop B8 was like a nice option not to
allow any counter play but then
instead um I guess he could uh he could
play G4 and then after Rook B7 Rook B8
uh I think it's pretty decent chances to
draw a game let's say if Rook
E8 some I know bishop move and G3 with
the idea of Rook E2 but instead he
played Bishop B4 and this is like hard
to believe but maybe this also holds in
in you know weird way so Bop scary is
for for black yeah but okay I didn't see
so what I saw like was like King B3 like
Bishop C7 Bishop
A7 uh let's say King D7 here so well
he's trying to run away with his King so
once he go gets to f8 I don't think it
will be something special and also I'm
even not so sure in this EV relations of
their position with an extra uh with
like three pieces for two Rooks and
three pawns yeah if I'm you know Pawn
lless so also it was like some fun line
here Bishop E5 like I wanted to play
like D5 Bishop
C5 and here let's say D6 and it would be
like
winning uh with D7 but there is always
Rook C2 like always Rook C2 so it never
works so here I should repeat and also
let's say here after Bishop C7 uh let's
say Bishop A7 if we trade trade King D7
Bishop
C5 uh would be smart but the problem is
here he plays Cas of D6 he takes takes
and plays this
and again and then okay Rook Knight on2
is um under attack yeah so that's also
some tricks here black could could only
be better so yeah it was hard to accept
but probably yeah uh some of these
positions should be should be good but
uh yeah it's really impressive how far
your preparation was in this game I mean
thank you just I mean it's impressive Al
I'm also impressed that ala managed to
hold it yes at the end what do you think
overall about the situation in the
tournament and what's happening right
now uh well uh it took only one day for
me not to come to the playing call to
everyone play a decisive game yeah so
now I'm back so hopefully the it would
be normal level of of draws but I think
Wesley did something horrible to do out
of the opening so I was quite shocked to
I mean
um so at you know at least he could try
like I don't know like CLE after Bishop
takes C4 but I mean instead he decided
just to you know losing three moves
maybe just b day for him but I guess
yeah there is a quite an interesting run
for
their uh rating spot for the candidates
yeah so like absolutely looks like
everyone is
invited actually it looks like that and
tomorrow you are playing with Wesley so
what do you think about
it no idea should first like let this
game go and then okay maybe I will start
freaking about the next one okay so all
the best of luck for you tomorrow Yan
thank you for coming today and we're
going back to the studio
you were interviewing nepo we have big
breaking